hi guys my name is ali wang and
unfortunately i am one of max's exes
you're pretty chipper for a victim about
to talk about the rest
i'm going to go ahead and skip most of
what she says because none of it is
important
so i'm one of max's exes and he did
stuff
i listen
everyone copes differently oh
she accuses me of being a
a stalker and a groomer
being that i am none of those things uh
if you guys are wondering what the
blurred out wars are uh imagine the
words are uh
all the it's grapes yeah you like grapes
you don't like this kind of crepe
it's the bad guy raisins
warning there might be a lot of growing
up
uh
whoever made these
then god damn
cut down the world
i'll have to win that night
thank you guys so much
and subscribe if you wanna like wanna do
whatever you wanna
bye
i found it very hurtful and was curious
why she was saying that about me so i
decided to reach out to her and ask her
why i broke up with you literally
because you were boring
say the least
i hooked up with you you know i broke up
with you oh okay otto is just cause you
were really born okay good we never hung
out we never did anything we never saw
each other even though we lived together
we never did anything i was bored as
[ __ ]
wild like
why all the weird accusations though
because i'm so tired of seeing these
[ __ ] 13 year olds
fan edits my ex-boyfriend who made me go
[ __ ] crazy because he was [ __ ]
crazy
so you're being spiteful
um i'm being mad
[Laughter]
what
did i try to kill you
no
no this is just a short clip taken from
a 30-minute phone call before she joined
the group chat with all of my other exes
i have added the full call in the
description censoring only personal
information
so basically because he was boring and
she was tired of seeing fan edits i've
heard him together
she was mad and she said this
you know how
whenever there's a new word that comes
in
the jargon of
that people are using like let's say the
word lit
right you have the word lit and then
everybody [ __ ] uses that word and
over you oh my god this is lit this is
so lit this [ __ ] microphone lit this
[ __ ] thing lit it's the same thing
with
all these terms in the eye as well
movement that's grooming uh
what happened
what happened it's funny to me when the
guy's 19 and she's 17 and everyone's
like
grooming i'm like hey hey
careful with that [ __ ] i know you i know
the human being won't really want to be
able to to to point and give an
etiquette a tag to something really
quickly but you're missing a lot of the
things and it becomes very dangerous on
both parts
having a failed justice system is fail
it's a failure to men and women
and i've and all these outlets believing
blindly everybody is
failing man and woman because we're just
gonna be real victims they're not gonna
be taken seriously at some point your
boat is gonna take it's gonna lose steam
every time somebody says the word
grooming
or
s-a
or i got i roll my eyes right off the
top
because i've seen people use that word
for literally any [ __ ] any [ __ ]
thing and so it's just like if you think
that is then why should i even listen to
like anything you think you don't even
understand the definition of words you
just say that [ __ ]
oh uh he's a 20 he's a he's a 35 year
old dating a 22 year old what this guy's
into children what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
what are you even saying a 19 year old
date's a 17 year old or like an 18 year
old it's a 16 year old which was like
super [ __ ] normal in high school okay
yeah
today people were like
grooming
like wait why wait what are we gonna
wait a minute
there's instances where people don't
want they want they want justice so bad
they want justice you want justice so
bad that you end up throwing the baby
with the bath water there you go i say
this spamless i don't know this dude i
don't know his past i don't know his
whole history i haven't done enough
research to know i just somebody sent me
this clip and i was i heard the voice
and sometimes you'll hear people like
why would anybody lie i don't know i
don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong i
don't know what happened to her
childhood i don't know why her egos but
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened all
i know is i've witnessed people make up
their craziest lives for no reason or
not a reason that i could understand
i've witnessed this y'all heard it right
now i was mad who makes up a [ __ ]
because they mad
oh you didn't take me out will i i
didn't like the videos that said we had
a great relationship i want to prove the
wrong what if i told the internet that
you tried to kill me what the who
[ __ ] i don't know
i don't know i can't i'm not even going
to spend the energy but but i'm not
going to spend the energy to sit here
and try to rationalize what i see as
[ __ ] crazy i don't i don't understand
everybody that says
who would do such a thing
haven't been with humans long enough
you haven't have
human interactions
long enough or you [ __ ] just stay in
your circle why would anybody like you
stay in your circle too much
you don't see what other people are like
you don't see how other people are
raised
you are in your circle too much yep
and you don't realize how human beings
are
men and women it's not a stab at woman
it's not a stab at man
that's you haven't had an interaction
with people long enough now does that
mean that i have to go the opposite and
be like it's not all believe all women
it's all women is [ __ ] lying hoes i'm
not saying that
you don't have to go from one extreme to
the oh that's exactly that's another
extreme that's not the point no you're
being stupid but but we do have to be
careful when we breathe this kind of
violence recently in spain
they passed a bill called yes means yes
okay
and one of the weirdest part about this
bill
the new bill defines consent as an
explicit expression of a person's will
making it clear that silence
or passivity do not equal consent so
it's not that you resist it's not that
you say
if you don't voice it it may not be
consensual think about what that means
think about what that means and let me
ask you this
let's say you agree with the whole bill
you say yeah women have to say yes out
loud
how do i prove
that she said yes out loud
if she says she changed her mind after
the fact says no i didn't say yes
he's lying bro i'm [ __ ]
but i heard her say yes that she wanted
no but nobody would say that well she's
the one who initiated the kiss and
pushed me down on the bed that she
didn't say
like nobody nobody when you read a lot
like this it's so ambiguous it looks
like it may lead to worse stuff
doesn't that look like that
when you hear language like that doesn't
it make you stop and ponder nah
and i understand you know the law that
spurned this in place was based off a
case where something very violent
happened to somebody and because of the
fact that um the men who attacked this
young woman um
claimed she never resisted
they were able to get off scot-free for
some time before the supreme court came
in and put them back in jail but there's
a lot of outrage over there and so in an
effort to fix what was a tragic
situation they went the complete
opposite way and went
we're gonna believe any woman anytime
because let's be honest let's all be
honest even though this isn't a gendered
law do you truly believe do you truly
believe
that if a man said come out and said uh
i didn't uh consent you think they're
gonna take that [ __ ] seriously
do you think they're you don't think
they want to take that [ __ ] of course
not so a lot of these things that you're
seeing unfold come from
like preach at a place of hurt from real
issues that exist in the world but the
over correction that we're seeing is
just meant
i
i don't see it having a good effect
people laugh i don't know what else to
say about people you know i stuff people
like nobody would like
they would [ __ ] lie for no reason
what do you want to say if you give the
opportunities the opportunity to someone
to lie they will
yep most most most time they will
believing that people oh no but i
believe in honesty and people are honest
and people are good people you haven't
been out
long
i know enough stories and there's
actually some stories online there was a
story about one girl who slept with this
dude in college
yes slept with a dude in college
people found out she said she got
creeped
man ended up going to jail lost all her
scholarship a year or two later found
out she was lying police pressed her she
admitted to it you want to know why she
lied because she liked another guy and
she didn't want him to think that she
was out here living her best life but
that only happens three percent of the
time listen
we always we always that's cap because
we we
we've always been talking about man like
the fact that we don't talk mental
health and stuff like that we don't talk
about a lot of [ __ ]
and you think that we're gonna talk
about [ __ ] like we do you think we
report as much as women do
imagine women not wanting to report i
understand why they don't want to report
i understand
the shame that comes to not wanting to
report
and on the other hand you have men
they're known to shutting the [ __ ] up
and moving the [ __ ] on
and dying of whatever because they
huh
and you're gonna believe that three
percent no we don't talk about it you
think i talk about my [ __ ]
i don't
to nobody ever
i should
but i don't
so if you think that three percent is
real it's a good thing that we have a
group when we're
we have a group of men that we talk we
talk and we just give her stories
and then one of us started opening up
about [ __ ] that happened in the industry
and everybody started to open up about
[ __ ] that happened in the industry
messed up stuff but do you think we
talked about it no you think it's
reported out of seven people
seven [ __ ] up stories we just we just
told one
seven [ __ ] up stories
that are untold to nobody else yep you
believe that three percent if you
believe in that three percent you're a
damn fool
hey man you were you were preaching
today
you're in your cup
thanks
i got nothing else man that that that
audio of that girl saying that [ __ ]
a couple years back would have triggered
the [ __ ] out of me now
i just don't got the energy for it but
disgusting
disgusting
and you know what here's the worst part
people will find out she lied
nothing's gonna happen nothing's gonna
happen nobody's even gonna look at her
sideways except for a few randoms on the
internet but had she succeeded imagine
what kind of damage she would have been
able to do that's the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] up [ __ ] it's like uh
but it's like it's like a it's an
investment
with zero risk
and only upside
think about that
you don't have to put in any capital you
just have to tell a few lies which is
super easy it's free there's no labor
cost just taking a story about amber
hurt
he had proof
tapes
her saying there's still some people
that believe her that's crazy yeah but
that's everybody's gonna take that to
this group hey it happens it was just
one
that was famous enough to be able to
and smart enough to be able to tape that
or whatever there's some stuff we just
don't talk about it we don't talk about
it
but they're gonna pass some of these
laws bro oh yeah if you get an
opportunity fight that [ __ ]